THIS AMERICAN SALAS NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS COURT CALL THE
ROLL. ARAMBULA BARRICADE HAND
BENNETT BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BURKE
CALDERON CORREO CERVANTES CHAU
GEN CHIU CHOI COOLEY COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM DALLY DAILY DAVIES
FLORA FONG FRAZIER FRIEDMAN
GABRIEL GALLAGHER CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON
GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA KILEY
LACKEY LIII LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA. MULLIN SUCI
THIS AREA WHEN O'DONNELL
PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK
QUIRK SILVA RAMOS RAY IS
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO.
SAY ARTURO SMITH STONE BEING
RELATIVE ERRORS THE OPRAH WHILE
VOEPEL WELLS WARD WHICH WORD
MISTER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR CHAMBER
AND IN THE GALLERY TO PLEASE
STAND FOR THE PRAYER. MEMBERS I
WILL NOT BE READING TODAY'S
PRAYER. SPIRIT OF LIFE WE KNOW
YOU BY MANY NAMES OR NO NAME AT
ALL HERE WE ARE GATHERED CALLED
TO SERVE. GIVE US PRESENCE OF
MIND TO LISTEN DEEPLY SPEAK
WITH CARE AND ALWAYS ACT FOR
PEACE FOR GOOD. AND FOR HEALING.
REGIS SPIRIT OF JUSTICE YOUR
BROUGHT US TO THIS NEW DAY A
POSSIBILITY IN HOME. AS WE
RECESSED TO OUR CONSTITUENTS
EMPOWER US TO ENGAGE IN
CONVERSATIONS THAT WILL SHED
LIGHT AND COMPASSION. AND
SUPPORT FOR MOST IMPORTANT
ACTIONS THIS YEAR. AND MAYBE
WHEN YOU ALL BE REMINDED AND
WHAT HAS GONE BEFORE AND IN
WHAT IS YET TO COME THAT YOU
ARE INDEED FAITH. HOPE AND LOVE.
WE ARE SIR GUESTS AND VISITORS
TO REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US
FOR THE FLAG SALUTE. PLEASE
JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT AS
HE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
SALUTE TO THE FLAG READY AGAIN.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG. OF THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA. AND TO THE REPUBLIC
FOR WHICH IT STANDS. ONE NATION
UNDER GOD. INDIVISIBLE WITH
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL. ASSEMBLY CHAIRMAN
SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY MARCH
TENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
ASSEMBLY MET AT SEVEN AM THE ON
WHICH IN THIS AREAS MOVES AND
MISS WALDRON SECONDS AT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE. INTRODUCTION
AND REFERENCE OF THE BILLS WILL
BE DEFERRED REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. THE
ABSENCES TODAY FOR PERSONAL
BUSINESS OR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FONG. AND FOR ILLNESS IN THE
FAMILY IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MULLIN. THREE IF YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WICKS COOLEY.
AND THE BONTA. TO SPEAK IN IN
THE GERMAN IN MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO CORRECT THE BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE
REPORT ON EIGHTY ELEVEN OH TOO
LOW AND ORDER THE BILL TO THE
FIRST DAY CONSENT CALENDAR FOR
MONDAY APRIL FIFTH. THE BILL
WAS INCORRECTLY REPORTED AS A
DO PASS. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. MISTER
SPEAKER ALSO WRITTEN REQUESTED
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
NINETY SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RE REFER TO THE
FOLLOWING BILLS TO COMMITTEE.
AB FOUR SIXTY EIGHT FRIEDMAN
FROM THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE TO THE BUSINESS OF
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE. AB FIVE
THIRTY FIVE AG WE ARE CURRY
FROM THE AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE
TO THE HEALTH COMMITTEE. EIGHTY
SEVEN EIGHTY TEAM FOR THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE TO THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE
AFTER THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
AB EIGHT FORTY NINE RADIOS FROM
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. AND I KNOW
WE'RE SO EXCITED TO HAVE OUR
FUTURE ATTORNEY GENERAL HERE
WITH US WE'LL GO TO GET THROUGH
TODAY SESSION QUICKLY AND THEN
EVERYBODY WILL HAVE TIME TO
CONGRATULATE. OUR OWN. AB TEN
TWENTY FRIEDMAN FROM THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE TO THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE AND THEN BACK TO THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE. AB TEN SIXTY
FOUR FONG FROM THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE TO THE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE. AB
ELEVEN ELEVEN BERMAN FROM THE
HOUSE AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
COMMITTEE TO THE HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE. AB ELEVEN
SIXTY NINE OF THE ONE OF THE
GARCIA FROM THE BUSINESS OF
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE TO THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE. AB THIRTEEN
SIXTY THREE THREE OF US FROM
THE HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE TO
THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE. AND
THE AB FIFTEEN THIRTY NINE
LEVINE FROM THE TO UTILITIES
AND ENERGY COMMITTEE TO THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. MEMBERS ALL
TAKE A MOMENT A PRIVILEGE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND WELCOME OUR
COLLEAGUES ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA AND CONGRATULATE HIM ON
THE ANNOUNCEMENT OF HIS
APPOINTMENT TO ATTORNEY GENERAL
YESTERDAY.
MOVING ON TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE
SECOND READING CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO EIGHTY SEVEN
WITH A MINUTES ONE TWELVE OF
THE MEMBERS THREE FORTY TWO
WITH A MEMBERS THREE EIGHTY ONE
WITH THE MINUTES FOR NINETY
THREE SEVEN SIXTEEN WITH A
MEMBERS FIFTY SEVEN WITH A
MEMBERS FIVE FIFTEEN WITH A
MINUTES TWENTY SIX OF THE
MEMBERS THREE AWAIT WITHIN
MINUTES. THREE FORTY ONE OF THE
MEMBERS FOR NINETEEN WITH A
MINUTES. TO FIFTY THREE TO
SIXTY THREE FIVE OH THREE C.
MOBILE THIRTY NINE OF THE
MINUTES FIVE FORTY THREE WITH A
MINUTES. FIVE SEVENTY SIX OF
THE MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
FIFTY ONE TO SEVENTY FIVE THREE
THIRTY SEVEN AND ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE OF TWO WITH MEMBERS. ALL
BILLS. BE DEEMED READ IT ALL
MINUTES WILL BE DEEMED ADOPTED.
WE WILL NOW BE MOVING ON TO THE
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING. FILE
ITEM TWENTY THREE HR TWENTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER ARAMBULA
CORKERY HOUSE RESOLUTION TWENTY
RELATIVE TO SAYS A SHOP IS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. SAYS
SERVICE PRODUCT CHAVEZ WAS BORN
IN YUMA ARIZONA ON MARCH THIRTY
FIRST NINETEEN TWENTY SEVEN. IN
THE LATE NINETEEN THIRTIES
AFTER LOOK THEY'RE LOSING THEIR
HOUSE IN A FOR CLOSURE HE AND
HIS FAMILY JOINED MORE THAN
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE
WHO MOVED TO CALIFORNIA DURING
THE GREAT DEPRESSION AND BECAME
MIGRANT FARM WORKERS. WITH ONLY
AN EIGHTH GRADE EDUCATION
CHAVEZ DROPPED OUT OF SCHOOL
AND BEGAN WORKING IN THE FIELDS
FULL TIME. IN NINETEEN FORTY
SIX HE JOINED THE U. S. NAVY
SERVING OUR COUNTRY'S FOR TWO
YEARS IN A SEGREGATED UNIT. IN
NINETEEN FIFTY TWO CHAVEZ WAS
WORKING AT A LUMBER YARD IN SAN
JOSE WHEN HE BECAME A
GRASSROOTS ORGANIZER. OVER THE%
NEXT DECADE HE WOULD REGISTER
NEW VOTERS AND FIGHT RACIAL AND
ECONOMIC DISCRIMINATION. THAT
SAME YEAR HE USED HIS LIFE
SAVINGS TO FUND THE NATIONAL
FARM WORKERS ASSOCIATION IN
DELANO CALIFORNIA. WORKING
DOGGEDLY TO BUILD THE N. W. F.
EIGHT ALONGSIDE FELLOW
ORGANIZER TO LOTUS WHAT THE
CHAVEZ TRAVELED AROUND THE SAN
JOAQUIN AND IMPERIAL VALLEY'S
TO RECRUIT UNION MEMBERS.
SUSSER THOMAS'S LIFE WAS
DEDICATED TO LOCK THOUSAND THE
STRUGGLE OF FARMWORKERS UNITED
STATES TO IMPROVE THEIR WORKING
AND LIVING CONDITIONS THROUGH
ORGANIZING. HE KNEW FIRST HAND
THE STRUGGLES OF THE NATION'S
POOR AND MOST POWERLESS WORKERS
THOSE WHO LABOR TO PUT FOOD ON
THE NATION'S TABLES WELL OFTEN
GOING HUNGRY THEMSELVES TODAY
THESE WORKERS STILL FACE THE
INEQUITIES. THAT SO SIR THOMAS
WORKED ON. SO HARD AND FOR SO
LONG THE LOW WAGES THE LACK OF
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE THE
INADEQUATE HOUSING AND
DISCRIMINATION. AS WE EMERGE
FROM THIS PANDEMIC THESE SAME
WORKERS HAVE BEEN CALLED
ESSENTIAL MEANING THAT OUR
STATE CANNOT FUNCTION WITHOUT
THEIR HARD WORK AND THEIR
COMMITMENT. AS WE CELEBRATE
THIS AMERICAN ICON WE MUST
NEVER FORGET THAT HE STOOD UP
FOR EQUALITY JUSTICE DIGNITY
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS. WE MUST
NOT IGNORE THAT THERE CLEARLY
IS A LOT OF WORK STILL FOR US
TO DO AND WE MUST RECOMMIT
OURSELVES TO LOCK I WAS UP WITH
ALL THE ENERGY AND
DETERMINATION OF THE GREAT SAYS
ARE CHAVEZ. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT WE BOTH HIGH ON THIS
RESOLUTION. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARAMBULA. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GONZALEZ YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR DESK. THANK
YOU I AM. MISTER SPEAKER ALL
BEGAN WHEN PEOPLE. GIVE THE
LEGACY IS AS A CHAVEZ THE
RESPECT IT DESERVES A LITTLE ON
THE FLOOR. SO I APPRECIATE THAT
YOU KNOW IN REALITY WE HAVE ONE
DAY A YEAR- I I'M RISING TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
IN SUPPORT ASSESSOR CHAVEZ
TODAY. AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO
START OFF TO SAY THE LEGACY OF
SUCH A TRAV IS AVAILABLE TO US
BECAUSE OF STRONG WOMEN THAT HE
SURROUNDED HIMSELF WITH. HIS
WIFE HELEN CHAVEZ AND OF COURSE
TOWARDS WORK THAT. THE CO
FOUNDER UFW WHO REALLY. BOTH OF
THEM ALLOWED THIS LEGACY TO BE
CREATED SO WE HAVE TO FIRST
GIVE THANKS TO THEM AS WELL.
BUT WHEN WE THINK ABOUT SAYS
HER CHAVEZ IN THIS TIME IT'S
IMPORTANT TO REALLY POINT OUT
WHAT HE WAS. TERRENAS FOR IT
PERHAPS WHEN HE WAS PREPARING
US FOR WAS THIS VERY LAST YEAR.
WHAT ARE MOST ESSENTIAL WORKERS
THE WORKERS TO ENSURE WE HAVE
FOOD ON THE TABLE. ARE ABLE TO
HAVE SOME PROTECTIONS.
HOPEFULLY THE PROTECTION TO BE
SAFE AT WORK ALTHOUGH THAT FEEL
THIS THIS YEAR HOPEFULLY THE
PROTECTION TO MAKE ENOUGH MONEY
THAT THEY CAN HAVE ADEQUATE
HEALTH CARE AND HOUSING
ALTHOUGH WE SAW THE FAILURES OF
THAT THIS YEAR. HOPEFULLY NOT
THAT THEY HAVE A VOICE ON THE
JOB SO THEY CAN ADVOCATE FOR
THEMSELVES. OF COURSE WE SAW
THAT FIELD THIS YEAR AS WELL.
SO IT'S REMINDING US TODAY.
AFTER THIS YEAR ONE PANDEMIC.
UNFORTUNATELY HOW MUCH WORK WE
STILL HAVE TO DEAL. SAYS CHAVEZ
SHOWED US WHAT WE NEEDED
DECADES AGO. AND WE CELEBRATE
THAT EVERY SINGLE YEAR AND WE
CELEBRATE WHAT HE STOOD FOR BUT
WE SO SELDOM SAY ARE WE TRULY
LIVING OUT HIS LEGACY HAVE WE
ACTUALLY DONE WHAT HE SET OUT
TO DO R. WE'VE JUST CELEBRATING
THAT HE TRIED TO GET IT DONE.
AND HE DID THE ADVANCEMENTS-THAT WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA FOR
FARMWORKERS. OUR INCREDIBLE
WHEN YOU LOOK AT OTHER STATES.
THAT'S A SAD STATEMENT. WHEN
YOU LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED THIS
YEAR TO FARMWORKERS THAT'S A
SAD STATEMENT BUT IN OTHER
STATES FARMWORKERS DON'T EVEN
HAVE THE RIGHT TO MINIMUM WAGE
THE RIGHT TO ORGANIZE THEY
DON'T HAVE THE RIGHT TO PAID.
OVERTIME SO WHAT WE STILL NEED
TO DO IN THIS COUNTRY TO OUR
MOST ESSENTIAL WORKERS. IT IS
INCREDIBLE AND THAT'S A CALL
FOR ALL OF US HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE SMALLER.
SO TODAY ON SEVEN CHAVEZ DAY
JUST LIKE EVERY DAY I ASK THAT
WE DO CELEBRATE HIS LEGACY. BUT
WE ALSO ASK OURSELVES WHAT
WE'RE DOING TO MAKE IT RIGHT IT
IS PROBABLY A SICK JOKE THAT
THE SUPREME COURT THIS WEEK.
HEARD A CASE ABOUT BASICALLY
THE RIGHT TO ACCESS WORKERS IN
ORDER THAT THEY CAN LEARN ABOUT
A UNION. OF THIS IS A U.
CALIFORNIA SPECIFIC CASE
BECAUSE ANOTHER STATE THEY
DON'T HAVE THE RIGHT TO JOIN A
UNION BUT THIS IS ABOUT ACCESS
TO THOSE WORKERS. AND IT'S SAD
BECAUSE WE KNOW. WHAT THE
SUPREME COURT WILL PROBABLY BE
SET BACK AGAIN. BUT SEVEN
CHAVEZ TAUGHT US TO NEVER QUIT
FIGHTING IN WE WOULD BE. WRONG
TO SUGGEST THAT WE HAVEN'T MADE
A VAMP SMITH'S TODAY I JUST
HOPE YOU'LL JOIN ME AS MY POST
ON SOCIAL MEDIA MAYBE SHOW FOR
BREAKFAST IN YOUR COMMUNITY.
CELEBRATES AS A CHAVEZ DO IT IN
A WAY THAT REALLY DOES. HE
RESPECTED HIS LEGACY AND SAYING
WHAT DO WE NEED TO DO NEXT THIS
PANDEMIC ED CHAU SHOWN US OUR
SHORTFALLS WHEN IT COMES TO
ESPECIALLY LATINO IMMIGRANT
WORKERS. AND WE HAVE TO DO
MORE. AND SO ON THE SETS ARE
CHAVEZ DAY HOPE YOU'LL VOTE YES
AND THINK ABOUT WHAT ELSE WE
CAN DO. OKAY THANK YOU MISS
GONZALEZ MR LEAD YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR CHAMBER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LGBT Q. CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF HR
TWENTY NINE POLICIES IT WILL
SERVE OUR SERVICE STOOD FOR THE
WORKER HE ALSO STOOD AS A
LEADER IN SUPPORTING LGBTQ PLUS
RIGHT. LONG BEFORE IS POPULAR
TO DO SO. HE UNDERSTOOD THAT
YOU DEBT YOU CAN'T DEMAND
EQUALITY FOR YOUR OWN PEOPLE
WELL TOLERATE DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST ANYONE ELSE CHáVEZ
BELIEVE THAT IF ANY MINORITIES
OPPRESSED WE ARE ALL RIGHT. IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN CHAVEZ
ATTENDED AND SPOKE AT THE
SECONDNATIONAL MARCH ON
WASHINGTON FOR LESBIAN AND GAY
RIGHTS HE LED MARCHES BOYCOTTS
OF HUNGER STRIKES HE CHALLENGE
PEOPLE TO BEGIN QUESTIONING
WHERE THEIR FOOD CAME FROM AND
WHETHER THE WORKERS PICKING THE
FOOD. WE'RE TREATED HUMANELY.
THE EFFORTS OF SUCH ARE SERVICE
OR REMINDER THAT TOGETHER WE
CAN BREAK DOWN BARRIERS IT'S
ONLY IN UNITY THAT WE CAN WORK
TOWARDS EQUITY INCLUSION FOR
ALL PEOPLE I HOPE YOU'LL JOIN
US IN SUPPORTING. HOUSE
RESOLUTION TWENTY NINE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU LEE. MR LOW YOUR
RECOGNIZING YOUR DESK. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER
AND COLLEAGUES I RISE ON BEHALF
OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS IN SUPPORT
OF HR TWENTY NINE TO
COMMEMORATE CESAR CHAVEZ DAY.
IT'S AN HONOR TO RECOGNIZE THIS
DAY IN THE LEGACY OF CIVIL
RIGHTS AND SOCIAL MOVEMENTS WE
COULD NOT BE MORE PROUD AS
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER CAUCUS
TO RECOGNIZE SITTER SHOPPERS
DATE AS WELL AS COMMAND ONE OF
OUR VERY OWN COLLEEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ROB BONTA ON HIS
APPOINTMENT AS ATTORNEY
GENERAL. HE ORGNIZED FILIPINO
AND MEXICAN FARM WORKERS AS
WELL AND HIS COMMITMENT WILL
CONTINUE ON THE LEGACY OF
SOCIAL JUSTICE AS YOU
RECOGNIZED HIS OUR SHOP AS DATE
WE KNOW THAT HE WILL HELP IN
THE BODY THE KEY ELEMENTS OF
THE MOVEMENT WE RECOGNIZE THIS
DAY IN SOLIDARITY AND SINCE HER
FATHER'S DAY ALONG THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER EXPERIENCE WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
AND SUPPORTING HR TWENTY NINE.
THANK YOU MR LOW. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEVINE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AT THE REAR THE
CHAMBER THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF H. R. TWENTY NINE.
WE'RE SO PROUD OF THE WAY THIS
IS OUR SHOP IS WORKING EVERY
DAY TO FIGHT. FOR THE DIGNITY
OF CALIFORNIA. BECAUSE OF OUR
SHARED VALUES. AS RELATIVELY
NEW IMMIGRANTS JEWISH TRADE
WORKERS PLAYED AN INTEGRAL ROLE
IN THE RISE OF LABOR IN THE NOT
LATE NINETEENTH AND EARLY
TWENTIETH CENTURY. JEWISH
LABOUR ACTIVIST SAMUEL GOMPERS
WAS THE FIRST PRESIDENT OF THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF LABOR
RUNNING THE UNION FOR ALMOST
FORTY YEARS AT THE SAME TIME
THE UNITED HEBREW TRADES BUILT
ITS POWER COUNTY. ONE HUNDRED
AND SIX JEWISH UNIONS UNDER ITS
UMBRELLA. SURE ENOUGH WHEN SAYS
HER FATHER STARTED ORGANIZING
TO FIGHT DEPRESSION OF LATINO
FARMWORKERS MANY JEWISH LEADERS
ROSE TO HIS SIDE. IN SOLIDARITY
SEVERAL ORTHODOX RABBIS URGE
THEIR CONGREGATIONS NOT TO BUY
NINE UNION GREATS DECLARING
THEIR THEM OCEAN. UNCLEAN
BECAUSE THEY CAME FROM
EXPLOITED LABOR. RABBI JOSEPH
GLAZER EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT
OF THE NOT A CENTRAL CONFERENCE
OF AMERICAN RABBIS SAID. UNTIL
THE PEOPLE WHO STOOPED AND SPOT
GO THROUGH ALL KINDS OF HELL
OUT THERE IN THE FIELD ARE
TREATED RIGHT. THOSE GREAT OUR
TRADE OR UNCLEAN. MEANING NOT
KOSHER TRAGICALLY SEVENTEEN
YEAR OLD MAN FRIEDMAN. A YOUNG
JEWISH WOMAN WAS THE FIRST
PERSON TO LOSE THEIR LIFE. ON A
FARM WORKER PICKET LINE SHE WAS
A COLLEGE STUDENT FROM BOSTON
WHO TRAVEL TO FLORIDA TO JOIN
THE STRIKE AGAINST. HOUSE
MENSUR COMPANY AND WAS KILLED
BY A TRUCK CRASH IN THE PICKET
LINE. CHAVEZ'S WIFE HELEN ONE
SHARED A STORY THAT WHEN THEIR
UNION WAS GAINING MOMENTUM
AFTER OPENING SEVERAL DONATION
CHECKS HER SISTER TURNED TO
HER. AND SAID HEY SISTER LOOK.
ALL OF THESE PEOPLE HAVE THE
SAME. NAME THE SAME FIRST NAME
ROW LEVINE. THE VOICE OF JEWISH
KING LEADER WERE SO PREVALENT
IN THE FARMWORKER MOVEMENT THAT
SAYS HER CHAVEZ BEGAN A
TRADITION HOSTING ANNUAL
PASSOVER CEDARS THE JEWISH
VALUE OF FIGHTING FOR JUSTICE
HAS NEVER STOPPED AT THE GATES
OF THE COMMUNITY TODAY AS WE
HONOR SAYS HER FATHER'S WE
RECOGNIZE THIS LONGSTANDING
JEWISH AND LATINO PARTNERSHIP
AND COMMIT TO CONTINUING TO
STRENGTHEN THIS COALITION IN
THE FIGHT AGAINST ALL
OPPRESSION AS WE WITNESS THE
RISE OF ACTS OF VIOLENCE
BIGOTRY TARGETING ETHNIC
COMMUNITIES WE STAND FIRM IN
THOSE VALUES AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK. FOR AN ITEM. THANK YOU MR
LEVINE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF ALL
THERE IS YOUR RECOGNIZING YOUR
DESK. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
OF SAYS ARE CHAVEZ DAY BECAUSETHIS IS A DEEPLY PERSONAL ISSUE
FOR ME. MY FAMILY FIRST CAME TO
CALIFORNIA IN NINETEEN ELEVEN
IN NINETEEN SEVENTEEN MY GREAT
GRANDFATHER APOLONIA VELASQUEZ
HAD ELEVEN DAUGHTERS IN DELANO
ARVIN IN BAKERSFIELD. ELEVEN
DAUGHTERS WHO ALL WORKED THE
FIELDS IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY MY
DAD WORKED THE FIELDS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY MY GRANDFATHER
HAD WAS ONE OF NINE ALL THE
FIELDS IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
MY FAMILY HAS STORY AFTER STORY
ABOUT THE WORKING CONDITIONS
THE LONG AT TWELVE HOUR DAYS
AND A HUNDRED AND FIVE HUNDRED
AND 10 DEGREES HEAT. WITH NO
BREAKS NO WATER EVEN ON MY
GRANDMOTHER'S WOULD PACK
RETAILS FOR LUNCH AND MY
GRANDFATHER WAS SHARE THAT WITH
ALL OF THE OTHER FARMWORKERS
PICKING IN THE FIELDS. MY
GRANDMOTHER WORKED ALONGSIDE
SAYS ARE CHAVEZ. WHAT CENTER
JOE HAVE A DID A OREGON. OUR
COMMUNITY AND FIGHTING FOR
FARMWORKERS FOR RIGHT FOR THE
LABOR MOVEMENT IS DEEPLY
IMPORTANT TO MY FAMILY AND
THEREFORE I AM PROUD HONORED
AND BLESSED TO SUPPORT SAYS ARE
CHAVEZ AND TO CONTINUE TO BE A
PART OF HIS MOVEMENT. ON BEHALF
OF MY FAMILY AND ALL OF THE
OTHERS HE HAS IMPACTED I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON HR. TWENTY NINE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISS WALTERS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR CHAMBER.
THANK YOU- MISTER SPEAKER IS
VICE CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
LATINO LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I
RISE THIS MORNING WITH. OUR
COLLEAGUES IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
HR TWENTY NINE WHICH HONORS THE
LIFE AND LEGACY OF CESSNOCK
TRAVIS. OTHER TRAVIS FAKTEN WAS
THE VOICE FOR SOME OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE WORKERS IN OUR STATE
AND IN THIS COUNTRY ARE
FARMWORKERS. THE WORK HE DID
ADVOCATING FOR FARMWORKERS
RIGHTS WAS REALLY A FIGHT FOR
HUMAN RIGHTS. THE RIGHT TO LIVE
WITHOUT OPPRESSION THE RIGHT TO
WORK WITHOUT HARM AND THE RIGHT
TO BE TREATED AS ANY OTHER
HUMAN BEING. BECAUSE OF HIS
WORK HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
FARM WORKERS. WERE PAID A FAIR
AND DECENT WAGE. FOR THE
DANGEROUS AND BACK BREAKING
WORK THAT THEY DID. IT WAS A
WAY THAT ALLOWED MANY OF THEM
TO LIVE WITH DIGNITY KNOWING
THAT THEY COULD SUPPORT A
CREATE A BETTER FUTURE FOR
THEIR FAMILIES. AND THIS PAST
YEAR'S REMINDED OUR COUNTRY OF
HOW ESSENTIAL FARMWORKERS ARE.
AND HOW ESSENTIAL AND CRITICAL
THEIR WORK IS. FROM THE COVER
NINETY PANDEMIC TO
UNPRECEDENTED WILDFIRE SEASON
FARMWORKERS HAVE PERSISTED. AND
THEY NEVER STOP WORKING SO THAT
OUR STATE OR COUNTRY COULD
CONTINUE TO BE FED. THEIR WORK
AND SACRIFICE IS A GREAT
REMINDER OF THE VALUES OF
SOCIAL JUSTICE OF WORKERS IN
HUMAN RIGHTS THAT SAYS ARE
CHAVEZ IN BODY. AND THAT WE
MUST CONTINUE TO BE PRIORITIZE
THAT WE MUST PRIORITIZE TODAY
HERE IN THIS CHAMBER AND IN ALL
PLACES MEMBERS ON YOUR DESK
YOU'LL FIND A CARD PRODUCED BY
LATINO CAUCUS. ALONG WITH A
COMMEMORATIVE FACEMASK. ON
BEHALF OF THE LATINO CAUCUS I
EXTEND OUR THANKS. TO OUR
COLLEAGUES IN FRESNO THE AUTHOR
OF THIS RESOLUTION FOR YOUR FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP AND HIS WORK ON
THE SUPPORT RESOLUTION AND ASK
ALL MEMBERS TO JOIN US IN
SUPPORTING HR TWENTY NINE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER RIVAS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER PROVIDING
OFFICER- ON BEHALF OF OUR
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS I ALSO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF HR TWENTY
NINE THIS MORNING TO HONOR AND
CELEBRATE SISTER CHAVEZ AND TO
RECOGNIZE THAT SIR CHAVEZ DAY A
STATE HOLIDAY THROUGHOUT
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. WITH
COURSE RECOGNIZED THE MAN AS A
VOICE FOR JUSTICE A LEADER WITH
COURAGE AND HUMANITY. AND A
CHAMPION FOR THE POWERLESS THE
SAME ISSUES THAT HE FOUGHT FOR
IN THE NINETEEN SIXTIES RING
TRUE TODAY ESPECIALLY WITH THE
BROWN BLACK COALITIONS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. AT WITH HIS LEGACY
WE LOST WE WANT TO RECOGNIZE
HIS COURAGE. IN TAKING. GREAT
LAKES TO SACRIFICE HIS LIFE FOR
THOSE IN NEED AND TO STAND UP
AGAINST STAND UP TO THOSE
THREATENED BY CHANGE. IT
CERTAINLY TAKES GREAT COURAGE
IN THE NINETEEN SIXTIES WELL
TODAY TO WALK WITH DELIVERANCE.
AND TO SIMPLY TAKE ACTION WHEN
ACTION IS NEEDED. AS I SAID
EARLIER THE COALITION'S BUILT
BY THE AFRICAN AMERICAN LATINO
COMMUNITIES IN THE NINETEEN
SIXTIES ARE CERTAINLY VERY
EVIDENT TODAY. WHETHER IT'S
WORKING ON ISSUES OF POLICE
REFORM CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM
VOTING RIGHTS EDUCATION EQUITY
ETHNIC STUDIES THESE POWERFUL
COALITIONS WERE IMPORTANT FOR
SUCCESS THEN AS THEY ARE TODAY.
I WILL LEAVE YOU WITH THE
LATTER THE FAMOUS LETTER TO DR
KING. WROTE WROTE TO CENSOR
CHAVEZ IN NINETEEN SIXTY SIX
THE TELEGRAM. PERMISSION TO
READ. HE NOTED OUR SEPARATE
STRUGGLES ARE REALLY ONE. A
STRUGGLE FOR FREEDOM FOR
DIGNITY AND FOR HUMANITY YOU
WHEN YOUR FELLOW WORKERS HAVE
DEMONSTRATED YOUR COMMITMENT.
TO RIGHTING GRIEVOUS WRONGS
FORCED UPON EXPLOITED PEOPLE.
WE ARE TOGETHER WITH YOU IN
SPIRIT AND DETERMINATION THAT
OUR DREAMS FOR A BETTER
TOMORROW WILL BE REALIZED LET'S
REMEMBER DR KING'S WORDS
DISASTER CHáVEZ NINETEEN SIXTY
SIX. THE FOCUS ON THE WORKING
CALIFORNIA TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR MCCARTY. MISS
WALDRON YOUR RECOGNIZING YOUR
DESK. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ARE RISE IN SUPPORT OF
HR TWENTY NINE COMMEMORATING
SAYS SAW SERVICE DAY. ON MARCH
THIRTY FIRST WE WILL RECOGNIZE
SAYS THOSE CHAVEZ IS A LEADER
WHO WORKED TO REPRESENT HIS
COMMUNITY AND TO PROMOTE
EQUALITY FOR ALL PHOTOSHOP HAS
DEDICATED HIS LIFE TO MAKE THE
LIVES OF OTHERS BETTER. HIS
FAITH AND COMMITMENT TO
NONVIOLENCE BROUGHT HUMAN
DIGNITY TO FARMWORKERS ACROSS
THE SOUTHWEST HIS IT EARLY ON
HE ADOPTED THE PATH OF
NONVIOLENT RESISTANCE FOR HIS
MOVEMENT. AND FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN THIS CENTURY MOST
AMERICANS BECAME AWARE OF THE
ISSUES OF MEN AND WOMEN WHO
LABOR TO PUT FOOD ON OUR TABLE.
AN ONEROUS SAYS A SHOP AS WE HE
WE HEAR IN THE LEGISLATURE ALL
HAVE THE CHANCE TO MAKE AN
IMPACT ON OUR COMMUNITY.
THERE'S OUR CHAVEZ ONCE SAID WE
CANNOT SEEK A TREATMENT FOR
OURSELVES AND FORGET ABOUT THE
PROGRESS AND PROSPERITY OF OUR
COMMUNITY. AYE ARJUN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS WALDRON.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR THE
CHAMBER. YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES IT'S WITH GREAT
HONOR THAT OUR RIGHTS TO IN
SUPPORT OF HR TWENTY NINE NORTH
THANK OUR COLLEAGUES IN FRESNO
FOR INTRODUCING THIS VERY POINT
RESOLUTION. EARLIER IN THE WEEK
WE TALKED ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF AGRICULTURE AND HOW. THIS
YEAR IT MEANT SOMETHING
DIFFERENT THAT THIS YEAR IT WAS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE HALL SIGNIFICANT-
CHAIN SUPPLY HAS BEEN TO OUR
STATE OUR NATION. TO EVERY
INDIVIDUAL WHO HAS NOT GONE
WITHOUT. FOOD INTERRUPTIONS-
WHETHER BE AT THE STORES AT
THEIR HOMES IN OUR SCHOOLS. AS
OF TODAY WHEN WE TALK ABOUT HR
TWENTY NINE IN COMMEMORATING
THE LIFE AND LEGACY OF SYSTEM
JOB IS. I THINK WE ARE ABLE TO
AMPLIFY. THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
HIS ROLE. IN THE WORK THAT IT
CONTINUES TO. SHAPE UP. AS IT
RELATES TO THE WORKING
CONDITIONS. AND MAKING SURE
THAT WE'RE PROTECTING THE
PUBLIC HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF
OUR FARMWORKERS. I'M VERY PROUD
TO STAND BEFORE YOU. AS A
NATIVE OF THE COACHELLA VALLEY
WHOSE PARENTS WORKED THE FIELD
AND IMPERIAL COUNTY. THE CELLO
BALLY ALL THE WAY DOWN TO THE
MONTEREY. COUNTY AREAS IN FACT
I TOLD THE STORY TO A COUPLE
COLLEAGUES RECENTLY THAT I
LEARNED. THAT MY MOTHER AND
FATHER WORKING IN THE FIELDING
GONZALEZ- IS WHERE THEY MET.
AND WHERE MAYBE I BECAME THAT
TWINKLE IN MY FATHER'S AYE I
HAD TO EVENTUALLY END UP. HERE
BEFORE YOU WHILE SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THIS RESOLUTION THE
FACT HERE IS THAT SAYS THAT
CHAVEZ HAD A TREMENDOUS. AS IN
THE NINETEEN SIXTIES OR
NINETEEN SEVENTIES THAT THE
FIRST. WAGES THAT WERE
INCREASED FOR FARMWORKERS DUE
TO THE GREAT STRIKE TOOK PLACE
IT WAS NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT
COACHELLA WHERE THE FIRST
PUBLIC SCHOOL WAS NAMED AFTER
SAYS AT TIMES IN THE ENTIRE
NATION AND IT WAS RECENTLY.
SURPRISINGLY IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
THAT THE CITY AND THE STUDENTS
FROM SUCH AS OUR MENTORING
SCHOOL PETITION THAT ONE OF THE
MAIN CORRIDORS BE RENAMED AFTER
SET UP CHAVEZ I'M VERY PROUD OF
THE HISTORY OF MY DISTRICT AND
THE CONNECTION TO SAYS THAT
CHAVEZ AND I THOUGHT. YOU KNOW
WHEN I THINK ABOUT THE CAUCUS
FOR THE MASK AND FOR THE
COMMEMORATIVE QUOTE HERE AND I
THOUGHT I'D READ IT IT'S A VERY
POWERFUL STATEMENT THAT IS TRUE
TO THIS DAY IN THE I HOPE THAT
AS WE PASSED A RESOLUTION WE
CONTINUE TO PUSH IN THE
DIRECTION OF. IMPROVING THE
LIVES OF FARMWORKERS UP AND
DOWN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THROUGHOUT THE NATION IT'S
IRONIC. THE IS STILL TOOL TILL
THE SOIL CALL TO AND HEART THE
FRUIT AND OTHER FOOD. THE
FIGURE TAPE WITH THE- AND LEFT
THEM SO AND THAT'S TRUTH.
BERMAN FARMWORKERS UP DOWNTOWN.
IS HERE EQUAL. THEY GIVE IS
THAT I'M NOT THE OTHER WILL BE
ONE OF SUCH A LOT BY WE HAVE-
THAT YOU THE STUDY MENTAL.
ALIEN ANSON'S MASS US WHEN I'M
DONE YEAH NOT IN. GILLIS SOLD.
BUT HE FEELS MEANS MOST MEN
LET'S CONTINUE TO FIGHT. FOR
ALL WORKERS IN. AND TODAY MORE
IMPORTANT. AS WE COMMIT SAYS A
CHILD WAS HR TO NINE FOUR
FARMWORKERS UP AND DOWN CAL.
AND BROADER NATION THANK YOU.
ALLOWING ME TO SEE. AND- YEAH
AS FOR AYE VOTE ON THE CHART.
NINE THANK YOU MISTER. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RECOGNIZING DESK THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS ARE
AND SO- TODAY HAVE SAYS ARE AS
THEY BUT I WOULD A SMALL I'M
JUST. ALWAYS TAKE A STEP BACK
IN AS WE TALKED THE BACK
ROLLOUT- UP AND DOWN THE STATE.
ONE OF THE COMMUNITIES IT'S
BEEN HERE HARDEST OUR FORMER
CAN- IS A- GUY THE RIVER
PRIMARILY ADD. WE ARE NOT.
SEEING THE VACCINE AVAILABLE TO
OUR FARM WORKING. IN THE NEXT
FEW MONTHS JERRY HARVEST
BLUEBERRIES STONE FRUIT ALL
LABOR INTENSIVE CROPS WILL BE
HIT PICKED WE'RE GONNA MEN AND
WOMEN IN OUR FIELDS. WE HAVE TO
ENSURE. THAT VACCINES ARE
AVAILABLE TO THIS COMMUNITY. IF
YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBERS THEY
ARE NOT SO I WOULD STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE THIS BODY TO STAY
FOCUSED ON THIS I WOULD
ENCOURAGE THE GOVERNOR TO TAKE
A LOOK AT IT AGAIN AND MAKES
SURE. THAT THE VACCINE ROLLOUTS
ARE COMING TO OUR FOREIGN
WORKERS BECAUSE THEY SO
DESPERATELY NEEDED ON A DAY
LIKE TODAY I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT WE MAKE THAT COMMENT
SO APPRECIATE YOU IN SUPPORT
THIS. THANK YOU MISTER FOR.
MADAM MAJORITY LEADER YOUR
RECOGNIZING ER DESK. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I I'VE SHARED
WITH- OUR MEMBERS THAT ARE TO
COME FROM PICKING ONIONS AND
GRAPES AND I'M VERY PROUD OF
THAT. I IN FACT WHEN I RAN FOR
OFFICE AND WON THAT WAS ONE OF
THE COMMENTS WAS MADE WHO WOULD
HAVE THOUGHT. THAT A YOUNG GIRL
WHO PICKED ONIONS IS A TWELVE
YEAR OLD WOULD ONE DAY HAVE AN
OFFICE HERE IN THIS GREAT STATE
CAPITOL. WHAT I APPRECIATE MOST
ABOUT SYSTEM TRAVIS. IS THAT
YOU DIDN'T JUST FIGHTS. FOR THE
FARMWORKERS HE FOUGHT FOR
EVERYONE. HE FOUGHT FOR OUR
COMMUNITY FOUGHT FOR DIGNITY
FOR INCLUSION. HE FOUGHT FOR
HUMANITY. AB MY COLLEAGUE A
MINORITY LEADER. FROM SAN
DIEGO. SHARE THE ONE QUOTE THAT
I THINK IS ONE OF THE MOST
APPROPRIATE. AND THAT IS. WE
CANNOT SEEK ADVANCEMENT FOR
OURSELVES AND FORGET ABOUT
PROGRESS AND PROSPERITY FOR OUR
COMMUNITY. NOT WHAT I MUST OF
THEM AT THE VERY BOTTOM LOCAL
MEAN MOST. YOU'LL BE I KNOW
THAT BUT I'M GONNA ON YOU
APPROACH THAT THE DENTIST MONEY.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE THINK OF
THE- THAT WE THINK OF WHAT WE
CAN DO BECAUSE OF THE POSITION
THAT WE HOLD TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE PROTECTIONS ARE NOT JUST
FOR OUR FAVORITES. BUT FOR THE
MOST VULNERABLE AND THE WANTS
TO AND WANTS TO NEED IT THE
MOST. I THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
FRESNO FOR BRINGING THIS
RESOLUTION. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS REYES SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE DAUGHTER
EMILY MAKE CLOTHES THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I'D LIKE TO TAKE
A MOMENT AND JUST THANK ALL MY
COLLEAGUES FROM BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE FROM THE MINORITY
LEADER TO THE MAJORITY LEADER
TO ALL O THE CAUCUSES WHO
STOOD IN SOLIDARITY FROM THE
API CAUCUS THE BLACK CAUCUS THE
LATINO POCKETS THE L. G. B. T.
AND THE JEWISH CAUCUS. IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE STAND UP AND
TAKE TODAY TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND
MEMORIALIZE AND RECOGNIZE SUCH
ARE CHAVEZ FOR ANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES WHO ARE DOUBTING IF
THEY CAN HIT THE GREEN BUTTON
ON THIS I WOULD SIMPLY SAY. SHE
STEP WHETHER. THANK YOU DOT
ARAMBULA AND I BELIEVE I HEARD
THE ONE THE FIRST ROLE OPEN FOR
CO AUTHORS THAT'S CORRECT OKAY
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
DOCTORS ALL MEMBERS VOTE YOU
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE
YOU DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THE CARD IS WALL THERE ARE
SEVENTY THREE CO AUTHORS ADDED
WE WILL NOW TAKE A VOICE VOTE
ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE. ALL THOSE
OPPOSED SAY NO. THE AYES HAVE
IT THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
THE SECOND DAY CONSENT CALENDAR
THERE ARE RESOLUTIONS ON
TODAY'S CONSENT CALENDAR.
BEFORE WE VOTE ON THAT CONSENT
CALENDAR WE WILL FIRST TAKE UP
THE RESOLUTIONS WHICH ARE ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR FOR THE
PURPOSES OF ADDING COAUTHORS.
THE CLERK WILL READ THE
RESOLUTIONS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FORTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RODRIGUEZ
RELATIVE TO AMERICAN RED CROSS
MONTH SOMETHING CURRENT
RESOLUTION FORTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHOI RELATIVE TO
ARTS EDUCATION MONTH. HOUSE
RESOLUTION THIRTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABLE RELATED TO
EDUCATION AND SHARING DAY
CALIFORNIA AND SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION SIXTEEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CABALLERO A
SIMILAR COMPANY OVER ANOTHER
SOLDIER TO WOMEN IN
CONSTRUCTION WEEK. WORKING OPEN
THE ROLE TO ALLOW ANY MEMBER
ADD ON AS A AUTHOR TO THE
RESOLUTIONS. MEMBERS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS ALL MEMBERS VOTE YOU
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
NUMBERS IF YOU WISH TO ADD HER
NAME IS CO AUTHOR THE RESUME ON
CONSENT PLEASE VOTE NOW. CLOSE
THE ROLE THERE ARE SEVEN ONE
AUTHOR. THE CLERK WILL ADD
THOSE CO AUTHORS OF THE RED.
THAT ARE ON CONSENT ALENDAR.
DURING A VOTE ON THE CAL DOES
MEMBER TO REMOVE AN ITEM FROM
THE HOW. MISTER MISTER SPEAKER
THREE OF THE PLAY REMOVE ITEM
TWENTY EIGHTY THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT THEY ARE QUE HAND FROM
THE- CALENDAR. CLERK WILL NOTE.
SEEING AND HEARING NO. REMOVAL
FROM THE CALENDAR A COUPLE THIS
I A CONSENT. SOME BILL EIGHTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER WARD AND
ACT RELATING TO HOUSING. CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON THE
CALENDAR ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEN THOSE
WHO DESIGN TO THE- ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. LOCAL
ROLE IN PALATABLE AND I FOUR
KNOWS THE CAN CAL IS A TOP.
WILL READ REMAINING I ON THE
COULD COUNT. ASSEMBLY CONCUR
RESOLUTION FORTY EIGHT. I
SEVENTY NINE ZERO SO CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FOR NINE SEVENTY
KNOWS HOUSE WAS LOOSE THIRTY I
SAID FOUR NO ZERO AND CONFIRM
RESOLUTION SIXTEEN I SAID FOUR
KNOWS. MEMBERS THE COURT HALL
IS NOT LIFTED. BEFORE WE MOVE
ON TO ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY WE
NEED TO WOULD LIKE TO RISE FOR
A MOMENT OF SILENCE. MEMBERS IN
THE PAST NINE DAYS WE HAVE SEEN
TO HORRIFIC MASS SHOOTINGS IN
OUR NATION. ONE ATLANTA GEORGIA
CLAIMING THE LIVES OF EIGHT
PEOPLE INCLUDING SEVEN WOMEN
SIX OF WHOM WERE OUR API.
BROTHERS AND SISTERS IN A
SHOOTING IN BOULDER COLORADO
TAKEN THE LIFE OF TEN MEN AND
WOMEN RANGING FROM THE AGES OF
TWENTY TO SIXTY FIVE. PLEASE
BEAR HEADS AS THE CALIFORNIA
ASSEMBLY PAUSES FOR A MOMENT
FIVE MOMENT OF SILENCE IN HONOR
THE MEMORY OF THE VICTIMS OF
GUN VIOLENCE. AND SOLIDARITY
WITH THE SURVIVING FAMILY
MEMBERS AND FRIENDS.
THANK YOU
MEMBERS. WITHOUT OBJECTION THE
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED AND WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED THE GERMANS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS IF YOU CAN PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS OR TAKE A
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR.
YEAH. MEMBERS OF I'LL ASK IF
YOU CAN TAKE YOUR SEATS TAKE
YOUR ALL THE FLOOR SO WE MAY
PROCEED WITH OUR GERMANS IN
MEMORY. THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS
ARE GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON AN INTERMITTENT
MEMORY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT THE WE
ARE THE REAR CHAMBER FOR YOUR
ADJOURNMENT MEMORY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS. I RISE
TODAY TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY.
OF HONORABLE ROBERT J.
CAMPBELL. BOB CAMPBELL WAS A
DEMOCRAT FROM RICHMOND
CALIFORNIA WHO REPRESENTED THE
ELEVENTH ASSEMBLY DESTRUCTION
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY. FOR
SIXTEEN YEARS FROM NINETEEN
EIGHTY TO NINETEEN NINETY SIX.
BOB CAMPBELL WAS RAISED BY HIS
MOM AND FEDERAL HOUSING TO THE
SHIPYARDS OF RICHMOND BEFORE
BEING ELECTED TO THE RICHMOND
CITY COUNCIL AFTER WORKING AS A
PARTNER. AND MA HACE INSURANCE
BROKERAGE. PROUD OF HIS.
OCCASION HERITAGE BOB GREW UP
WITH- EMERGE IN RICH CULTURAL.
OF THOSE THAT HE REPRESENTED.
AS A MEMBER OF THE ASSEMBLY
POPULATED BY HAVING A STAFF
COMPRISED OF MOSTLY WOMEN
SOMETHING THAT IS SADLY AS
UNCOMMON TODAY AS IT WAS BACK
THEN. HE WAS ALSO APPOINTED BY
SPEAKER WILLIE BROWN TO SERVE
AS THE CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY
WAYS AND MEANS BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION. AND THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE. THERE WASN'T IT THIS
WAS IN ADDITION TO HIS OTHER
COMMITTEE ASSIGNMENTS WHICH
INCLUDED AGRICULTURE EDUCATION
HIGHER EDUCATION PUBLIC SAFETY.
REVENUE TAXATION. WATERS PARKS
AND WILDLIFE COMMITTEES.
WHETHER HE WAS AT HOME IN THIS
DISTRICT ARE HERE IN THE
CAPITOL OFFICE BOB WORKING BODY
JUST OF INCLUDE AND SERVICE.
HIS JOB AS A LEGISLATOR WAS.
FOR HIM BECAUSE HE WITNESSED
HOW PEOPLE IN RURAL AND URBAN
AREAS WORKED IN STRUGGLE TO
MAKE A LIFE FOR THEMSELVES AND
THEIR FAMILIES. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BARB WENT. ABOVE AND BEYOND
PERSONALLY HELPING CONSTITUENTS
WHEN HE COULD INCLUDING
ASSISTING A YOUNG HOMELESS
COUPLE WHEN THE MOTHER WENT
INTO LABOR. ONE OF HIS STAFFERS
COACH THE EXPECTANT MOTHER
THROUGH HER CONTRACTIONS WILL
BARBARA FOR THE HOSPITAL WHERE
SHE SAFELY DELIVERED HER BABY.
HE ALSO MADE SURE THE COUPLE
GOT INTO TRANSITIONAL HOUSING.
IT IS CAPACITIES BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE CHAIR BOB KRIST
CALIFORNIA'S EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS TO BROADEN AND
PROVE THEIR EFFORTS TO ASSIST
TRADITIONAL AND NONTRADITIONAL
STUDENTS. HE ALSO STRESSED THE
NEED TO PROVIDE A CLEAR PATHWAY
FOR HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES BOTH
THROUGH OCCASIONAL TECHNICAL
EDUCATION TO LEARN A TRADE AND
THROUGH COLLEGE FOR OTHER
PROFESSIONS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CAMPBELL ALSO
SUPPORTED BALLOT MEASURES AND
CARRIED LEGISLATION TO PROTECT
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA.
WATERWAYS AND HELP PRESERVE
FISHERIES IN CLEAN WATER BY HIS
RING AROUND THE BAY LEGISLATION.
BOB CAMPBELL ALSO HELP FIGHT
FOR VETERANS BY AUTHORIZING THE
BILL TO ESTABLISH. CALIFORNIA'S
PURPLE HEART LICENSE PLATE A
SPECIAL PLATE THE RECOGNIZES
VETERANS. WHO HAVE RECEIVED THE
DISTINGUISHED HONOR AT THAT
IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE MARIA
MARIA THE VERMONT TAY'S
CHILDREN LISA AND KURT CAMPBELL
ANDRES UMEDA ARE MONDO AND
DAVID THE VERMONT TAY'S AND
GRAND CHILDREN ANDREW VEREMOS
TAY'S- JOAQUIN CAMPBELL. AND
LIBYA YOU READ A- AND DAUGHTER
IN LAW. TAOS HOKKIEN AND CARRY
HER. AND OF OTHER FRIENDS AND-
I RESPECT REQUEST THAT WE THE
MEMBER OF ON A ROLL BOB
CAMPBELL. THANK YOU MAY WORKS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHO YOUR IN THE
REAR THE CHAMBER YOUR INJURY
NUMBER. FOR CALLING IT'S AGREED
ON TO STAND ON GREEN. AND
REMEMBER BOB CAMPBELL. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHO I KNEW IN MY- IT'S A
RUMOR ON THIS PART WITH A DE.
THAT THE QUALITY REPRESENT IN
THIS ROOM SO MUCH A PRICE. OF
THE INDIVIDUAL LINE THAT
BROUGHT YOU. BOB CAMPBELL IS A
NATIVE CALIFORNIA WHO WAS. BORN
IN LOS ANGELES. HE WAS
INDEPENDENT AGENT WHOSE
INSURANCE IS A SMALL BUSINESS
PERSON. HE WAS WENT TO COLLEGE
IT. CONTRA COSTA COLLEGE THEN
SAN FRANCISCO STATE HE GOT HIS
MASTERS AT UC BERKELEY. EVERY
UC BERKELEY HE WENT ON TO TEACH
POLITICAL HISTORY. AND THAT'S
WHEN YOU REALLY START TO FEEL
THERE IS A QUALITY OF BOB
CAMPBELL'S LINE TO PURSUE THEM
HERE WHICH IS SORT OF THE
ACCIDENTAL BYSTANDER. THAT SET
YOU UP FOR LIFE HE WAS ON THE
BERKELEY CAMPUS TO POLITICAL
HISTORY. BETWEEN. NINETEEN
SIXTY THREE TO NINETEEN SIXTY
FIVE SOYBEANS BOB CAMPBELL
FUTURE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WAS
THERE AT THE BIRTH OF THE FREE
SPEECH MOVEMENT. HE WENT ON TO
ELECTED AS WE JUST WITH. SO
COUNCIL NINETY SEVENTIES. BUT I
CAN ATTEST TO THINK OF PUBLIC
SERVICE FOR THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES AFTER AMERICAN
PRESIDENT HAVE RESIGNED THEIR
OFFICES JUST BRACE. WAS REALLY
TO RESOLVE TO BRING HIGH IDEALS
TO PUBLIC SERVICE. WE GET SO
CONTRARY TO WHAT HAD BEEN
PROMINENT IN THE NEWS. IN THAT
ROLE HE SERVE THE PEOPLE OF THE
CITY OF RICHMOND. WAS ACTIVE IN
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ACTIVITIES J.
SHE'S OTHER SORTS OF THINGS
UNTIL HE WAS ELECTED TO THE
ASSEMBLY IN NINETEEN EIGHTY. IT
ALSO MEANS THAT BOB CAMPBELL
LIKE ALL OF US IN THIS ROOM.
CERTAINLY A TIME WHEN THE
CHAMBERS THE ROOMS THEY WORKED
IN CHANGE BECAUSE OF REMODELING
THROUGH SORT OF A MODEL OF US
IN THAT WAY. BUT CAMPBELL THIS
BUSINESS PERSON TO ALSO A CAN
AND STATES. SERVED IN THE ARMY
RESERVE. AND A CALIFORNIA
NATIONAL GUARD. BECAME THIS
MEMBER AND I'M THAT LIFE YOU
SERVICE SEE WHAT HE BROUGHT TO
A. HE WAS CERTAINLY HIGHLY
REGARD HERE AND CAPITAL OF
COMMITTED AGAINST OF THE- A
VERY OUTGOING JONES ALL HAD A
WAY OF. GREAT THAN A MOMENT TO
OF LEVEL TAKE A- STEP BACK. HE
WAS A OF WHAT WAS TERMED A
GRIZZLY. HISTORIC LIBERAL CALL
OF THE ERA. WHICH INCLUDED
CLOTHES FOR. WHICH ARE
DANGEROUS. REFER SO HIGHLY.
JOHN BURTON JOHN VASCONCELLOS.
SAM FOR JACKIE SPEAR. HILLS SO
MAX WATER. BOB CAMPBELL WAS A
TRUE LIBERAL GROWING UP IN A
VERY KAREN FROM IS TO. I JUST
BUSINESS PERSON A LOT OFFICIAL.
HE WAS CAN AS A MEMBER THE END
OF HE- HELD IN A CALM RECORD
RATE. HE WAS FOR BEING ABOUT.
THE STORY TOLD HE WAS ONCE AT
EIGHT WITH MANY OTHER DIDN'T
HAVE. AND SOMETHING WAS GOING
ON AND ALSO WAS LOOK FOR BOB
CAMPBELL THEY DON'T FIND IT
BECAUSE YOU JUST TALK TO FOR.
IN THE PARKWAY THE EVENT IS
TAKING. TO HE WORKED ACROSS THE
AISLE DURING TENURE. IN THIS
BUILDING. ON ISSUES. OF
POLITICAL PARTY GEOGRAPHIC
BROWN. HE WAS VERY ENGAGE AND
SOLVE PROBLEMS FOR THE WHOLE
STATE. AND CATTLE THAT OF
LEADER. IN THE BODY. ANY READ
BOTH A GOOD FOR VIEWS. ARE
HEARTS STAFF MEMBERS FROM COLOR
PARTY EVEN. WHICH IS SORT OF
PROCESS HIS THAT GRANT HIS
OPENNESS TO WIDE. IN IT HAS
SPEECH HERE IN THIS ROOM. I'M
SURE THAT ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT HERE DURING HIS
TENURE THE CAPITAL. WAS TO AT
AN ISSUE FROM ELSE POINT OF
VIEW. AND ACCEPTED OTHER. CAN
HAVE A TO DIFFERENT YEAH
PERSONAL ON A- THIS ALLOW HIM
TO BE. A RECONCILING DIVERGENT
VIEWPOINTS AND GIVE LEADERSHIP.
WE AS A BODY CONTINUE TO
BENEFIT FROM BOB CAMPBELL.
WELCOMING AND COMPASS IN
PHILOSOPHY AND APPROACH. IN
MOST YEARS EACH COOPER HOLDS A
RETREAT. THIS WAS ORIGINALLY
FROM AN ORGAN BY BY HIM. WHO
TOOK THE FIRST RETREAT TO A
SPOT NOW CLOSE CALL THE RED
ROAD SPORTS COME. IN MY JUST
ANDRE ROAD. ANOTHER OF HIS
LEGACY IS STAFF. HE HAD DIED
THE INTER CALLS STAFF WRITERS
YEAR LARGER. MANY OF THEM ONE
ON THE OTHER PUBLIC OFFICE.
AMONG THOSE THAT YOU READ OUR
DAILY ALBERY WE CAN CHECK FOR
SENATE. JOHN WALDIE CHIU FOR
OFFICER THE MEDIA PER FOR
DEBORAH. ANIMA K. RULES D.
ROADWAY CHIEF DEPUTY TRADE.
CHOOSES TO WORK WITH AT A THIRD
HOUSE AND MY RETURN- MY RETURN
TO BE. DEPUTY FORTY. AND COULD
FOR AND CHAMBER. BOB CAMPBELL
MADE FOR AND ON THE SERVER MADE
A PROFOUND AND HERE. BECAUSE OF
WHAT HE BROUGHT HERE IT IS A
REMINDER THAT EVERY DAY OF THIS
MATTERS AND THE VIEWS. ESPOUSED
BY EACH ONE MATTERS WE TOGETHER
A BETTER FUTURE FOR OUR STATE.
AND I CAN TRUCK WE ASKED WE-
ADJOURNED AND MEMORY OF. ROBERT
JOSEPH CAMPBELL FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU MR COOLEY
MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE NAME
OF THE DEAD TO BE PRINTED IN
THE- ALL REQUESTS TO ADJOURN IN
THE WILL BE READ PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL. MOVING TO AND- MEMBERS
OF. THE TO BE OPEN UNTIL TWO.
MARCH THE- AT THREE P. TO
PROCESS CAN REPORT AN AUTHOR
AMENDMENTS. THE SCHEDULE AS
FOLLOWS FRIDAY MAY TWENTY
THROUGH APRIL IS RE. MY APRIL
FIFTH SESSIONS ONE PM. ALL
OTHER ITEMS FROM IT REMAINING
WILL BE PASSED RETAIN ALL
MOTIONS OF THE CONTINUED
SEARING AND SEEING AND HEARING
AT NO FURTHER BUSINESS I'M
READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN SUMMER NAZARIAN MOVES
AND SOME OF THEIR LACKEYS
SECONDS THAT. THE HOUSE STAND
ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY APRIL
FIFTH AT ONE PM ENJOY YOUR
SPRING RECESS.